Rhonda Sanders just says whatever he
thinks the political base wants to hear
in a given moment he doesn't have
independent of it thoughts of his own he
responds to Twitter and the effects of
it
um so I don't know what Rhonda Sanders
thinks I just know what comes out of his
mouth reflects what he thinks is going
to achieve that dopamine hit in getting
a Twitter Trend he is someone who like
you has put the sort of fight against
so-called corporate wokeness on the
front burner uh he is fighting this
battle with Disney right now in Florida
if that is kind of at the center of both
of your campaigns why should people opt
for you or take a closer look at you
versus you know a popular two-term
governor in Florida
so the popular two-time governor in
Florida has been good as an executor in
certain respects not as good as he would
make it out to be but I think that's a
that's a separate discussion for another
day
the question is who do you want in the
white house do you want a Visionary who
has their own ideas or do you want a guy
who executes other people's ideas and I
think there's a role for everyone in the
system but I think when we're in the
middle of this national identity crisis
in our country I don't think we want a
follower in that in the white house I
think we need an independent thinker and
a leader and the case I make for
Effectiveness too is that Rhonda said
this is like a billiard ball you hit him
in a given Direction he'll go in that
direction
but he doesn't know why he's heading in
that direction he's not the one doing
the aiming and that results in loss of
Effectiveness so let's just take the
Disney thing for example what he says he
is doing it's laughable is that he's
rolling back the special protections
that Disney shouldn't have been given in
the first place I
I agree with that I don't like chronic
capitalism I don't like special forms of
corporate protections that are the
product of lobbying what the media
completely missed it shows you how to
sleep at the switch even the media is
is that some of those corporate
Privileges and special protections were
signed into law just a couple of years
ago by wait for it Ron DeSantis actually
and I can go into the details of what
those were those included exemptions
from the political anti-discrimination
statute that he passed there was a
special exemption if you own a theme
park more than 25 acres in the State of
Florida that was signed by Governor Ron
DeSantis and then he strips that after
the fact saying that oh we should have
never had these chronic capitalist
Protections in the first place that's a
joke because he was actually the one of
the ones who signed it in the first
place anyhow and so I think that that
state action
um you know argument or that lurking
State action piece I think is is a bit
of a farce and I think that you know I
think that he ruins the credibility of
his own Crusade by not knowing why he
was doing in the first place and by the
way Disney then gets the better of him
in the end by the day before his new
governing board takes over completely
castrating that board of having any
power so execution's missing we should
shift to a discussion question of woke
capitalism since that's a big top
recurring topic of your campaign and
your books the most recent to uh at
least and there's been a lot of comments
uh to that regard one uh here says just
FYI I'm not voting for anyone whose
platform includes waging a war with
wokism because your ideas essentially
based off censoring other species
I mean I can kind of speak to that
concern a little bit and yeah you can
respond to this because I live in Rhonda
Sanchez's Florida and I've watched him
Advance things like the stop woke act
that's his attempt to
stop wokeness from encroaching into the
schools and into Corporate America and
to my mind the way it's been done here
is a pretty clear violation of free
speech rights it's it's perfect sloppy I
think Rhonda's end is a slot because he
doesn't have an understanding of why
he's doing what he's doing I think that
and and it's a shame that he has screwed
this up in many ways that have folks
like yourselves maybe and personal ask
that question understandably irritated
when somebody says they're fighting
wokeness first of all that's how I'm
labeled I never actually say that I'm
waging a war on wokeness I say I want a
crusade to revive a missing national
identity those are different things
that's what's me versus Rhonda Sanders
is different is not a book called yes
and and I named that book at a time
where most people didn't know what the
word woke does and that woke was and it
actually offers the most rigorous
definition of what we're actually
talking about that a bunch of Republican
puppets then take and run with and
bastardize what it actually means and so
yes I did I wrote the book on it try
reading the book and figure and whoever
asked the question
will have a very different impression
after reading them yeah yeah give a
quick summary then of how uh battling
wokeness does not get the government
into policing what is and is not
permissible speech either in the public
sphere or in the in Corporate America so
that's the question to ask it's called
awoke Inc for a reason the ink part is
actually what's doing the work so a lot
of this is top-down government driven in
the first place that's what we need to
see that's what Rhonda Santos by the way
fails to see that's what I think a lot
of the people who are just going through
the motions of criticizing wokeness fail
to see let's talk about woke capitalism
ESG movement that's not the free market
that's an illusion don't fall for the
trick that is not the Invisible Hand of
the free market
that is the invisible fist of government
which should make every libertarian's
blood boil so do not you they are they
are trying to use your language back
against you and I say your I mean strong
libertarian instincts used to call
myself one not that long ago right
they're weaponizing the language to dupe
you into thinking that this is the
evidence of the free market when in fact
it's lurking State action the entire
time I also tell conservatives I coach
them stop talking about big Tech
censorship
it's not it's government Tech censorship
because then government is using a
combination of threats and special
immunities and coordination
to do through the back door what
government couldn't do through the front
door would you uh arm wrestle Ron
DeSantis if he agreed to sit down with
you I probably would yeah why not that
was the reason live stream with Vivek
ramaswamy who's running for the
Republican nomination for president and
has just published capitalist punishment
a book length diatribe against ESG and
other aspects of what he considers woke
capitalism if you want to watch the full
conversation go here if you want to
watch another excerpt go here and come
back next Thursday every Thursday at 1pm
when Zach weismuller and I are talking
to somebody even more interesting than
the last week thanks for watching